pendant des années bruny surin a tout
tenté pour résoudre son problème
d'arthrose du genou
j'avais tellement mal je vois même pas
marcher normalement parce qu'à chaque
fois que je fais je vais fouler
j'avais l'impression c'est comme si on
prenait une aiguille on met leur entrée
dans un verre sans ce test est vraiment
à penne l'arthrose du genou est un mal
qui touche près d'un québécois sur six
quand un genou est en santé les cats
l'âge qu'ils protègent glissent
facilement l'un sur l'autre
mais dès que l'arthrose comment ça les
endommager l'usure et la déformation
crée de la douleur c'est finalement une
nouvelle approche médicale développer au
québec qui a soulagé champion olympique
la jeune graphie il s'agit d'un test
biomécanique extrêmement précis qui
mesure tous les mouvements du genou d'un
patient et permet d'identifier ceux qui
sont mal exécutée même les plus subtiles
un peu comme un électrocardiogramme vous
avez une courbe et selon les amplitudes
vous pouvez déterminer certaines
maladies là c'est la même chose ça
permet de dire qu'est ce qui fonctionne
pas une fois qu'on a cerné le problème
on passe en mode solution qu'on leur
propose en fait une fois les déficits
mesure et on leur propose un plan de
traitement qui peut être soit des
orthèses de pied ou deux jours mais
surtout aussi des exercices à faire à la
maison qui essaie de corriger des
facteurs mécaniques à risques identifiés
chez ce patient avec différents
exercices adaptés spécifiquement son cas
l'état de bruny surin s'est rapidement
amélioré ce soit que j'avais pour faire
un sprint je n'aurais pas fait exprès
pour au pourboire pour me reblesser
institué mai
l'essentiel pour moi c'est de marcher
faire nos activités physiques et aussi
au point de vue ici de dire que j'ai
réglé mon problème
les genoux graphie a fait récemment
l'objet d'une importante étude clinique
qui regroupait 450 patients
les résultats sont impressionnants une
diminution de 40% de la douleur
ressentie par les participants on nous
on est on est aussi quelque chose qui en
fait peut être un peu plus précis que je
suis dit il on prend des médicaments
tous les podiums en fait d'une
infiltration
une centaine des patients de ce médecin
y ont participé ça fera pas les
cartilages a fait un nom mais si on
fonctionne bien sans douleur puis on est
capable de nos activités de la vie de
tous les jours pour 65 ans qu'est ce que
ça donne un objectif de vie bah c'est
merveilleux est-ce qu'on devra offrir à
chaque québécois qui souffrent
d'arthrose du genou
un examen semblables c'est la question à
laquelle la prochaine étude devrait
répondre ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal